aufregung bei den nacktmullen es ist
zeit zum saubermachen
sie sind hier nicht in ihrer heimat den
ostafrikanischen halbwüsten sondern in
einem berliner labor und der strengen
hygiene bedingungen sorgt klägerin
gabriela pflanzt fürs wohlbefinden
ein bau aus röhrensystem errichten
nacktmulle normalerweise unter der erde
also hier sind meistens sind
schlafzimmer mit sieht man ja da wo das
laufband ist sozusagen der fitnessraum
ergebnis kleine wie wenn meistens als
toilette benutzt
nacktmulle leben in kolonien
ungewöhnlich für ein säugetier wie bei
insekten gibt es arbeiter soldaten und
eine königin die die jungen bekommt
außerdem hat sich der nacktmull im laufe
der evolution an extremen
lebensbedingungen anpassen müssen
das führte zu besonderen eigenschaften
für die sich die wissenschaft brennend
interessiert der molekularbiologe gary
lunn erforscht den nacktmull seit
mehreren jahren
wir wollen die molekularen veränderungen
entdecken aufgrund derer sich das genom
während der evolution so entwickelt hat
dass der nacktmull diese extremen
fähigkeiten erlangt
so haben die forscher mechanismen in den
zellen entschlüsselt die dazu führen
dass nacktmulle kaum schmerzempfinden
erkenntnisse die in schmerztherapien für
den menschen hin sollen jetzt sind die
wissenschaftler einer weiteren
besonderheit im genom des nacktmulls auf
der spur
er sieht nicht so aus aber er bleibt
quasi ewig jung und lebt für ein
nagetier außergewöhnlich lang weil sie
30 jahre alt werden können ohne krank zu
werden wollen wir herausfinden was an
ihrem stoffwechsel besonders ist denn
das schützt sie vor krankheiten wie
diabetes herz und krebserkrankungen
fütterungszeit der nacktmull markt
pflanzen
außerdem trinkt er kein wasser das
gewinner aus der nahrung auch eine
anpassung an die lebensbedingungen in
trockenen regionen in seinen
unterirdischen höhlen herrscht zudem ein
hoher kohlendioxidgehalt der nacktmull
hat gelernt mit wenig sauerstoff
auszukommen
diese deckt die das ist wirklich ein
interessantes phänomen weil es für den
menschen nützlich sein kann zum beispiel
bei einem schlaganfall oder das
hauptproblem ist dass das gehirn dadurch
geschädigt wird und das liegt daran das
ist zu wenig sauerstoff bekommt den 80
ist ein besonderes forschungsobjekt
daher sich nur sparsam vermehrt wollen
die forscher seine molekularen
geheimnisse auch auf anderem weg
entschlüsseln mit nierenzellen des
lagers und modernen methoden der
stammzellforschung
wir versuchen aus der nierenzellen
stammzellen zu machen aus denen wiederum
zum beispiel hören oder
bauchspeicheldrüsen zellen entstehen
können dann brauchen wir nicht mehr den
nacktmull selbst oder sein gewebe
sondern können diese zellen für unsere
experimente nutzen
die nager sollen sich hier wohlfühlen
für die tierpflegerin ist das nicht nur
ein job
sie hat auch selbst etwas davon also
wenn ich viel mal ärger habe oder ein
bisschen stress bin ich wenn ich hier
herkomme und hab die tiere bin ich die
ruhe wieder selber die nacktmulle bergen
noch einige geheimnisse zielstrebig wie
die tiere selbst arbeitete die
wissenschaft daran auch die zu
entschlüsseln